So today we're going to continue with
our study of auctions and we're going to
study uh a bit of a richer model than
the example that we looked at so far.
But let's just recall what we've done so
far with auctions.
So far we looked at this uh very simple
example where we just had two biders and
each bidder's valuation for the item was
uniformly distributed on the 01
interval. So let's look at this example.
We had our example
where we had two biders
and their valuations V1 through and V2
were independent
and uniform
on the interval 01.
And we looked at the at two different
auction formats in this simple example.
The first auction format would be a
first price auction.
Remember, in a first price auction, each
bidder submits a bid. The person who
submits a higher bid wins the item. And
the amount that they pay is the amount
of their bid. And what we showed is that
in a first price auction, at least in
this example, we had an equilibrium
where each bidder bid exactly half of
her valuation.
So we had an equilibrium where maybe B1
star of V1 equals V1 over two and B2
star of V2 equals V2 over two. So this
was a symmetric equilibrium. Each bidder
bids exactly the same way given their
valuation. And of course, we notice that
each bidder is always going to bid
strictly less than their true valuation.
If they bid their true valuation, well,
they could never come out ahead because
even if they won the auction, they'd end
up paying exactly what they value the
good for. So this way, there's a chance
that when they win or or when they do
win, they're always paying strictly less
than their valuation for the good.
Another auction you could run is a
second price auction.
And in a second price auction, the
biders submit their bids just like in a
first price auction. And the rule for
allocating the good is the same as in a
first price auction. The person who bids
the most gets the item. The difference
from a first price auction is the
payment rule. So in a second price
auction, the winning bidder doesn't pay
their own bid, but they pay the second
highest bid. That is the highest bid
among everyone else. And we argued
informally that in the second price
auction, it's optimal to bid your true
valuation. So here we have an
equilibrium where B1 star of V1 equals
V1
and B2 star of V2 equals V2. And I want
to start by arguing why this is
equilibrium. why you always want to bid
exactly your true valuation in a second
price auction.
So to see this let's consider a second
price auction spa and let's take the
perspective of bidder one.
So suppose I'm bidder one and suppose my
valuation for the good is V1
and we want to look at different ways I
could bid. Okay, so we want to argue
that it's always better to bid my true
valuation V1 than to make a different
bid. Well, how could I bid differently?
Well, there's two rough ways I could bid
differently. I could either bid more
than my valuation or less than my
valuation. So we're going to analyze
those two those two cases separately. So
let's think about
our bid space here.
So this is zero and let's fix our
valuation here V1.
And we want to first see well what if
instead of bidding my true valuation V1
I chose an alternative bid B1 prime that
was say here.
So I'm contemplating a deviation where
instead of bidding B1, instead of
bidding V1, I bid B1 prime. So I bid
strictly higher than my true valuation.
And we want to argue that this can never
help me, right? That I'm I'm never
better off by bidding B1 prime than I am
bidding V1. And to see this, well, what
happens in this auction is going to
depend on what the other bidder bids. So
I want to think of this axis here as
representing what the other bidder is
bidding. And that I want to compare the
performance of this bid to this bid for
each possible way that the other player
bids. So let's first start down here.
Suppose the other player B2, the other
player makes a bid B2 that is down here.
It's strictly smaller than V1. Okay. So
what happens if I bid V1? And what
happens if I bid B1 prime?
Let's start. What if I bid V1 and the
other player bids B2? What happens?
What's the outcome of the second price
auction? Yeah. The front
>> you pay B2, right?
>> You pay B2 and you win the good and you
and you win the good, right? What if you
had instead bid B1 prime?
>> Yeah.
>> The same thing,
>> same outcome, right? So if if the
opponent's bid is down here, it doesn't
make a difference whether I bid V1 or B1
prime. Either way, I win the item and I
pay the bid B2. So here we'll say no
difference
between V1 and B1 prime. What if B2 is
up here?
Now what happens if I bid V1 and if I
bid B1 prime? Yeah,
>> you lose.
>> You lose either way. So here it also
doesn't make a difference, right?
They're out bidding me whether I bid B1
prime or V1. So I lose. I don't get the
item and I don't pay anything. So it
makes no difference.
What if they bid in here?
[clears throat]
And we could worry about them bidding
exactly V1 or exactly B1 prime, but you
know that just sort of adds some
complication. So let's say it's strictly
between V1 and B1 prime. Now what
happens if I bid V1?
I lose, right? Because I've been outbid
by my opponent. So I get zero.
If I instead bid B1 prime, well, this
sounds pretty good because now I win. I
win the auction. But what happens if I
win by bidding B1 prime when my opponent
bids B2 here?
>> Yeah,
>> you're paying for the draft valuation.
>> So, I'm actually worse off here because
I could bid my true valuation V1, win,
pay nothing, and win nothing and my
payoff is zero. Or if I bid B1 prime, I
out bid my opponent. I win the item, but
now I have to pay the second highest
bid, which in this case is B2. So I'm
paying more for the item than it's
actually worth to me. So I'm strictly
worse off by bidding B1 prime than V1.
So in this case, I'll say V1 is strictly
preferred. This is kind of a squiggly uh
to B1 prime. So there's three separate
cases we've analyzed. In two of the
cases, it doesn't matter whether I bid
V1 or B1 prime. And in one of the cases,
I strictly prefer bidding my true
valuation of V1 to bidding B1 prime. So
the argument is almost done, but we only
considered bids strictly higher than my
valuation. We now have to go through the
same argument and make sure that I never
want to bid strictly less than my
valuation. So let's go through the same
thing over here.
So same figure, here's V1,
but now we're going to contemplate a
downward bid. And you might think this
is sort of the more common bid when we
played the uh or the more common mistake
when we played this the first price or
the second price auction. Uh some people
actually most people bid pretty well but
some people bid strictly less than their
valuation. So let's see uh whether this
is a good idea. And let's again analyze
our three cases.
Again I say three cases we have to be a
little careful if it's right here but uh
it's not going to change anything.
So case one. What if my opponent's bid
is down here? It's strictly lower than
B1 prime and it's strictly lower than
V1. Well, same thing. I lose either way.
Sorry, I win either way and I pay B2
either way. So, there's no difference
up here. Well, I'm being outbid. B2 is
strictly higher than V1 and it's
strictly higher than B1 prime. So
whether I bid my true valuation or B1
prime, I lose the auction. I pay
nothing. I get nothing. And therefore,
it makes no difference.
But again, the critical region is this
middle region
where my opponent's bid B2 is strictly
between B1 prime and V1. So what happens
here if I bid truthfully and bid V1?
Yeah,
>> you win it and pay B2,
>> right? And what if I had instead bid B1
prime?
>> Lose.
>> I'd lose, right? So, I'm better off
bidding truthfully because I win and pay
less than my valuation. So, I make a
strictly positive utility. Whereas, if I
had deviated and bid B1 prime, I would
have lost the auction, won nothing, paid
nothing, and therefore got a utility of
zero. So once again we see that V1 is
strictly better than V1 prime.
So now we've sort of completed our
graphical argument to show that bidding
truthfully is better than bidding
anything else. And in fact what we've
shown is that bidding truthfully is
actually a weekly dominant strategy. So
normally with auction equilibria in say
first price auctions the best way for
you to bid depends on the way your
opponent bids. In this case, bidding
truthfully is best no matter how your
opponent bids, no matter what strategy
your opponent uses. Yes.
>> Uh I may have
>> Why isn't like bidding P1 prime when
your opponent bids P2 all the way at the
bottom better than doing P1? Like don't
you pay?
>> Let's see. So you're in there's six
cases here. So you're in this one case
one
>> or
>> this the like graph on the right.
>> Okay.
>> And so you see
>> and and here.
>> Yeah. Okay, great. Let's go over this.
So, let's suppose my opponent bids B2
here, right? Okay. What happens if I bid
V1?
>> It's because it's second price auction.
It wouldn't be true if it was a first
price auction, right? Either way, I win.
And the crucial point about a second
price auction is when I win, the amount
I pay doesn't depend on what I bid. So,
the crucial property of a second price
auction is my bid can affect whether I
win. But if I win, the amount I pay does
not depend on my bid. It only depends on
my opponent's bid. Um, so in this case,
if I bid here or here, I win either way
and I pay B2. Good. Okay. All right. So
now we've analyzed this example. I think
you can see that this kind of argument
is actually going to extend. We didn't
really use the uniform distribution
here, right? This is a much more general
property of second price auctions that
it's optimal to bid truthfully. But I
want to make one kind of interesting
observation here. We've looked at two
different auction formats and we've
solved for an equilibrium in each
auction format. So a natural question to
ask is which auction format is better
for the auctioneer. Okay,
which auction
does the auctioneer prefer?
Well, to say prefer, we have to talk
about the auctioneer's preferences.
Let's assume that the auctioneer likes
money and they're risk neutral. So the
goal of the auctioneer is to maximize
their expected revenue in the auction.
Okay. So now let's compute their
expected revenue in the first price
auction.
Well, let's first just look at their
revenue. Maybe we'll call it pi. Pi is
good notation for revenue. So what is
their revenue in the first price
auction?
If bidder 1's value for the good is V1
and bidder 2's value for the good is V2
and the biders are following the first
price auction strategy.
Well, that means bidder one is going to
bid V1 over2.
Bidder two is going to bid V2 over2. And
how much revenue then am I going to make
as the auctioneer?
Yeah,
>> whichever of those is larger,
>> right? So, one way of writing that
mathematically is just the maximum of
these two, right? We're going to make
the maximum of V1 over two and V2 over
two. Why? Well, this is how much player
one bids. This is how much player two
bids in a first price auction. I collect
the higher bid because the higher bidder
wins the item and pays their bid. So if
V1 over2 is bigger they're going to
player one wins the auction and pays V1
over2. If bidder 2's bid is higher that
is if V2 over2 is higher then bidder two
wins the auction they pay their bid V2
over2 and this is what I get. So this is
telling me what my revenue is for a
given realization of the valuations of
uh the two biders. But now I want to
take expectations here. So my expected
revenue
is equal to the expectation of this.
Maybe as a trick, I'll just pull out the
half. I can always, you know, the max of
V1 over2 and V2 over2 is just half of
the maximum of V1 and V2. So maybe I'll
write this as 1/2 of the expectation
of the max of V1 V2.
Okay.
And
this is a expression that comes up a lot
for uniform random variables. It turns
out the answer to this this expectation
is 2/3. But I want to give a little
geometric argument for that. Uh but
let's just fill it in. If this is 2/3
and I multiply it by a half, then what
I'm going to get is 1/3. Okay,
where did this 2/3 uh magically come
from? Well, let's think. Well, first
does the number make sense? I mean v1
and v2 are both uniformly distributed on
01, right? So this number should be
between 0 and one. That makes sense. Now
the expectation of V1 by itself is a
half, right? If you're uniformly
distributed on 01, the expectation is a
half. So certainly it makes sense that
the expectation of the maximum of these
two numbers should be higher than the
expectation of just one of them. So we'd
expect to get a number between 1/2 and
one. So 2/3 makes sense. Why do we get
exactly 2/3? Um there's actually a
really nice geometric argument that I
want to show you. So we could think of
v_sub1 and v2
as living on this line right maybe
here's v2 maybe here's v1 and these are
uniformly distributed right the trick is
actually to connect this line to make it
a circle right so now let's view this as
a circle
where this is this point is
zero and one so I basically taken this
and I've just bent it around to look
like this right uh so now I have v2
and
v1 here.
Well, now the
maximum
of v1 and v2 is going to be
this length,
right?
But now if I think about the circle,
because things are uniformly
distributed, I basically just have three
uniformly distributed points on the
circle. I mean, this one is a a fixed
point. It's not uniform, but it's as if
it's uniform. It wouldn't make a
difference. So if I have three points on
a circle, the expected distance between
any any consecutive ones is going to be
1/3. In expectation, this is a third,
this is a third, and this is a third. So
the expectation of two of the segments
is going to be 2/3. It's maybe not quite
a rigorous argument, but um I think that
should give you intuition for why this
expectation is 2/3, right? Because you
just effectively have three points uh on
the circle.
Okay. So now we see that in the first
price auction the designer's expected
revenue is 1/3. Let's now look at the
second price auction.
So in the second price auction,
if bidder 1's valuation is V1, bidder
2's valuation is V2
and both biders follow their equilibrium
strategy of bidding truthfully, then
what is the auctioneer's revenue going
to be in this case? Yeah,
>> the minimum of
>> the minimum of V1 and V2, right?
Because in this case, bidder one bids
V1. Bidder two bids V2. The higher
bidder wins the item, but they don't pay
their own bid. They pay the second
highest bid. Which in this case, what's
the second highest bid? It's the minimum
of these two bids. If there's only two
bids, the second highest is the minimum
of the two. So, here we sort of nicely
see the trade-off. In a first price
auction, you get the higher of the two
bids, but each of the bids is smaller
because the the biders anticipate that
it's a first price auction, so they
shade their bids downward. In a second
price auction, you get the lower of the
two bids. That hurts the the auctioneer,
but the benefit is people are bidding
higher because they're bidding their
true valuations. So the question is
which of these two forces uh wins? Well,
let's uh let's compute this. we get the
expectation of pi big pi I guess of v1
v2
equals well just the expectation
of the min of v1 v2 and if we use our
little graph over there can we guess
what this expectation is
oneird right because now I have these
three points on the circle the minimum
of the two is just going to be the
length of the segment between two
consecutive between two consecutive
points. So it's going to be half as big
as the length uh between uh over two
segments. So I'm exactly going to get
one.
So what you see here is actually these
two effects I described exactly offset.
In the first price auction, you get paid
the highest bid, but people choose to
bid less. In the second price auction,
you get the smaller bid, but people
choose to bid more. and those two
effects exactly offset and the
designer's expected revenue is exactly a
third in each case. Now, this was a very
simple example with uniform
distributions. So, you might think, oh,
this is just a coincidence. This is a
fluke. It turns out this is a very deep
and general phenomenon that many
different auction formats will generate
the same expected revenue uh for the
auctioneer. And that's something that
we'll uh we'll talk about a bit later in
the course. Any questions on this?
Yes.
>> Trick for finding the maximum minimum is
that if you had one
>> exactly yeah so maybe let's write this
down. Uh so if I did if everything was
uniform 01 and I had uh n I had v1
through vn then the expectation
of the max of v1 through vn and this is
kind of a good fact to know uh guess can
you see what what if we complete the
pattern we got 2/3 when n was two what
do you think this is going to be now
>> exactly Right?
And in fact, you can actually go
further. If I wanted the expectation of
the second highest, it would be n minus
one over n+1. The third highest n -2
over n plus1 all the way down to the
expectation of the min
equals
1 n + one. So there's a very nice
structure. I could look at the lowest,
the second lowest, the third lowest, all
the way up to the highest. And those are
exactly going to be equally spaced uh
and they're separated exactly by one
over n plus one.
And you can use calculus to verify this,
but I think this is sort of a nice
intuition for what what goes on. And you
could try to formalize that.
Any other questions?
All right. So now as I said this was a
very simple example. You might worry
that our conclusions are really
sensitive to that. So we need to now
what we want to do now is study a more
general auction setup where instead of
two biders we have n biders and instead
of assuming their valuations are
uniformly distributed we allow for more
general valuations. So we're going to
look at a more general model.
So we're going to look at in general
what's maybe called the uh symmetric
independent
private values model. Let me explain
what these words mean as we go through.
So now we're going to have n biders. So
we have biders
i equals
1 up to n
And the biders are symmetric in the
sense that the distribution from which
each bidder's valuation is drawn is the
same. So you you know of course when we
actually run the auction, someone might
value the good more than someone else.
But before we start the auction, we
don't believe that the distribution of
one player's valuation is higher than
the distribution of another player's
valuation. In reality, this is probably
not a great assumption, but this
simplifies things and we can talk later
about how it extends. So, what does that
mean? It means that for each bitter i,
the valuation
vi.
Well, before we said the valuation was
in 01. Let's be a little more general.
Let's say this lives in the interval
between v lower bar and the upper bar.
So, this is the lowest possible
valuation a bidder could have and this
is the highest possible valuation that a
bidder could have. Notice I don't have
subscripts here because the range of
valuations is the same for all the
players. It doesn't depend on the
identity of the bidder. And we'll say
this is
distributed
according to
a CDF, that's a cumulative distribution
function, capital F, and a PDF, a
probability density function, little F.
And I'll explain what these mean.
So this is just a way to describe a
distribution. If you've taken a
probability class, which is I think
technically a prereitive for this, you
would have uh gone over this. But what
are these things? Well,
f of v
just tells us the probability that the
valuation is below v. So f of v is
defined to be the probability that say
vi is less than or equal to v.
So f is an increasing function. If I
plug in v lower bar, I'm going to get
zero because the probability that vi is
below v lower bar is zero.
If I plug in V upper bar,
then I'm going to get one because the
probability that V that VI is less than
equal to V upper bar is one. And then
it's going to fill in in between. When I
say it has a PDF, what that means is I
can express this probability as an
integral from V lower bar to V of F ofX
DX.
So that means we can visualize the
distribution.
Here's the lower bar. Here's the upper
bar by
some density like this.
And what this says the peaks say these
are places where the valuation is very
likely to be and then the valleys are
places where the valuation is less
likely to be. And
what we're saying is if we fix V here
under this curve is exactly the
probability that the valuation lies
between V lower bar and V. So what that
means one implication of that is that it
must be that the area under the entire
curve is one because the probability
that V lives somewhere is just one.
That's just a fact of probabilities. So
this is probably a little quick if you
haven't seen this before. um that is a
prerect for the course and I'm happy to
chat after or maybe you can self-study
if uh if you haven't seen probability
distributions or densities before.
Okay, so symmetry refers to the fact
that we're using the same distribution f
and little f for all the bidters. It's
not varying across the bids.
Uh independence means that vub1
through vn are statistically
independent.
This is the same assumption we made in
the example. It's that if I know my
valuation V1, that doesn't allow me to
update my beliefs about other players
valuations. So, what it rules out is
things like positive or negative
correlation where when one bidder's
valuation is high, everyone else's
valuation tends to be high or when one
bidder's valuation is low, everyone
else's valuation tends to be low. Uh
this is also maybe a strong assumption
and we can again maybe talk later about
how it could be relaxed but uh this is
what we're going to assume for today.
And I should maybe say one thing about
these end points. I'm going to assume
that zero
is less than or equal to v bar
strictly less than v upper bar. So the
agents always assign a non- negative
value to the good. I think this is a
pretty safe assumption. If they really
hated the good, they could just throw it
away. So, we're always assuming that
they value it at least zero. They could
value it at zero, but they never value
it at a negative number.
So, we've talked about symmetry, we've
talked about independence,
what private values refers to, and maybe
I'll give us the acronym. This is SIPV.
Private values refers to the fact that
each bidder knows exactly how much he
values the good and bidder I's valuation
doesn't depend on other players
valuations. So you might imagine if we
were in an auction for a painting and
there was a chance that I could resell
the painting. I might care about how
much other people value the painting
because if they value the painting more
I might think, wow, I could resell it to
them after the auction and therefore my
valuation for the painting goes up. So,
we're ruling that out by assuming
private values. We're assuming that I
know my evaluation for the good and how
much I'm willing to pay depends only on
my signal about say how much I like the
painting and not about not on how much
anyone else likes the painting.
Okay, so here we are and we're going to
try to analyze the first price auction.
Uh we're going to try to solve for an
equilibrium of the first price auction.
So goal
solve for B&E a bay Nash equilibrium of
the first price auction in the SIPV
setting.
I'll use a lot of acronyms of FPA
the first price auction
in the SIPV
setting.
Right? Notice the setting and the
auction are different. The setting is
about who's involved and how much they
value the good. The auction format,
these are the rules that the designer
gets to choose or the auctioneer gets to
choose, right? The auctioneer can't
choose how much people value the good.
This is just a fact of the world. This
is a fact of the setting. But the
auction format is something that uh is
chosen by the auctioneer.
Okay. Well, first as always, we have to
figure out well what is a strategy for
each player. So what is a strategy for
player I?
Well, a strategy needs to say how much
does player I bid
as a function of their valuation for the
good. So a strategy for player I arrow
is going to be a function bi
from
maybe I'll write
this So what does this mean?
It means that for each valuation of the
item that I could actually have, BI is
my bidding function. Sometimes that's
the terminology we'll use.
My bidding function says for each
valuation say VI that I could have my
bidding function spits out BI of VI
which is the bid that I will make if my
valuation is VI. And just using the
rules of the auction we're assuming that
bids can be any non- negative number. I
can't bid a negative amount. I can't ask
the autor to pay me. That would be a bit
strange. Uh but I can bid any non-
negative number that I want.
And an equilibrium is going to specify a
strategy profile. So it's going to
specify a bidding function for each of
the n biders. So as as before, this is
uh kind of a difficult problem because
we're trying to solve for functions, not
just single numbers. And these are
really big. There's a lot of we're you
know each player is choosing infinitely
many numbers. How they bid if the
valuation is one. How they bid if the
valuation is two, 2.3, 2.5. there's too
much too many things to solve for
before. Recall that we got around this
by guessing. We guessed that the there'd
be an equilibrium where each bidding
function was just a linear function. And
that simplified things a lot. It reduced
our problem to just solving for a single
parameter. But that only worked in the
special uniform example. So beyond the
uniform distribution, there's no reason
to think that people are going to use a
linear bidding function and bid exactly,
you know, one-third of their valuation
or one half of their valuation. So we
have to be a bit more general. So what
we're going to do is we're going to also
make a guess. So, we're going to guess
or look for
um a
symmetric
increasing
differentiable
equilibrium.
Let's go through what all these words
mean. Well, we're going to look for an
equilibrium where every bidder uses the
bidding function beta
from vb bar.
So we're going to say look because the
biders are x anti- symmetric their
valuations are drawn from the same
distribution we're going to look for an
equilibrium where all the biders use the
same bidding function the same strategy.
So bidder one bidder two all the way up
to bidder n use this function beta. So
if you wanted to be formal, what we're
saying is B1 equals B2ALS
BN equals beta.
So everyone uses the same bidding
function and we're assuming that this
bidding function is increasing. That
makes sense. If you value the good more,
it seems intuitive that you should bid
more for the item because you care more
uh you you assign more uh utility to
winning the item. you want to increase
your probability of winning.
And this is just kind of a technical
mathematical assumption. We want to be
able to apply calculus. So we're going
to assume that beta is differentiable.
That is we can always take the
derivative of of beta beta prime. And
that that derivative is always going to
be strictly positive. That's basically
increasing a little stronger than
increasing.
And now we've kind of reduced our
problem. Instead of looking for n
arbitrary bidding functions, we're now
looking for a single bidding function
beta and we want to see if we can find
an equilibrium where every single bidder
uses this bidding function beta. Um, any
any questions here on on our approach
because we're going to get into a little
math. So I want to make sure the the
approach is clear.
Okay. So what do we need to do? How are
we going to solve for beta? Well, if
this is going to be an equilibrium, it
better be that if everyone else is
following the bidding strategy beta, the
bidding function beta, it's optimal for
me to also choose the bidding uh
strategy beta. Right? So, what we want
to say is let's consider let's focus on
bidder one. It just makes it a little
easier.
So, so put yourself in the shoes of
bidder one. Suppose that and I'm going
to write define a function here. U1
of B1
given
V1 beta.
Let me describe in words what this
means. I want to say I'm bitter one.
What do I know? Well, I know my true
valuation for the good is V1. So, this
is my valuation.
And let me suppose that all of my
opponents are following the bidding
strategy beta. So what I'm supposing
here is that B1 B sorry B2 equals B3
equals BN equals beta. So I assume that
player two is using the bidding function
beta. Player three is using the bidding
function beta all the way up to player N
is also using the bidding function beta.
And I want to say okay here I am. I
believe that my opponent's using this
this these bidding functions. I know my
true valuation V1 for the good. What I
want to compute is what is my utility if
I were to bid B1. So B1 is just a
number.
This is not a function. It's just a
number. Right?
And once I compute this function, then I
can start thinking about then I can
maximize this function and find the
optimal bid for me. Right? But I need to
put in this information because the best
way for me to bid in this auction is
going to depend on how much I value the
good and it's also going to depend on
what I believe my opponents are using.
So that's why I need all this notation
here.
And this is sort of the key quantity.
So
let's try to any guesses can we
write out what this uh what this
expression is going to be? Well, let's
think it through, right? If I lose the
auction, my payoff is zero, right?
Because if I lose, I don't get the good
and I don't pay anything. So, we just
have to figure out, well, what is my
utility going to be? Let's suppose I
win. If I win and my valuation is V1 and
my bid is B1, then what will my utility
be if I win?
>> Yeah.
>> Exactly. Right. Uh,
so this is my utility if I win.
But I only get that utility if I do win.
So now I have to multiply that by the
probability that I actually win, right?
What is the probability that I win?
Well, it's the probability that well,
what does it mean for me to win? I win
if my bid is higher than everyone else's
bid. Now, there's always this question
of ties because this bidding function is
are strictly increasing.
Any single bid by my opponents is going
to have probability zero. So I don't
really have to worry about ties. So let
me just put in the probability uh maybe
that my bid is strictly higher than all
my opponents. So that's the probability
that B1 is greater than well it has to
be greater than how much B2 bids B3 bids
before well that's just the maximum. Let
me just take the maximum of all of their
bits. Right? So I'm going to say the
maximum
over maybe J
uh let me write it out explicitly of
beta V2
all the way up to beta.
Okay.
I think again there's always this
confusion. You see a probability and
then you see B1 and people sort of think
B1 is random. No, I know what B1 is. B1
is just a number. What I don't know is
how much my opponents are going to bid
because even if I believe they're using
this strategy beta, I don't know what
their actual valuations are. And their
actual valuations affect how much they
actually bid. So if I bid B1, I'm going
to win if player two's bid is small,
player 3's bid is small, player N's bid
is small, all of their bids are small
enough. That is the maximum of all their
bids is smaller than my bid.
>> Yeah.
because increasing
>> uh here I'm actually about to use that
fact. I don't actually need to use it
here. Um uh so I guess this statement
doesn't even doesn't use the fact that
beta is increasing. What where that will
come in is when will beta of v2 be
small? It will be small if v2 is small.
That's where increasingness comes in. If
beta were not increasing then maybe I'd
win when my opponent's value is really
high because that's when they bid low.
So there will be a step where we use the
fact that beta is increasing. But for
now, we actually haven't used that fact
because I win if my bid is higher than
everyone else's bid. It doesn't matter
whether their bidding functions are
increasing or decreasing or or crazy,
right? But that will come up. Yeah.
Okay. So
now we will exactly go the next step.
Let's let's kind of analyze this
probability here, right? Um well,
since beta is increasing,
which of these players is going to bid
the most? Well, beta is increasing and
they're all using the same bidding
function. So, which of my opponents is
going to bid the most? Yeah,
>> the opponent that has the highest value.
>> The opponent who has the highest value.
Right? So, actually, I don't need to go
all the way down. Let me just go here. I
can simplify this expression as just
writing this is beta of the maximum
of v2 up to vn.
And here I am using the fact that beta
is increasing because I'm saying the
player who bids the most is exactly
going to be the player who values the
good the most. So, so in words this is
the maximum of the bids of my opponents.
In words, this is the bid of my opponent
who has the highest value. And because
beta is increasing, these two are going
to be the same.
Great. Now we can simplify it a little
bit more. um
this is the random thing and we want to
sort of focus on that. So let's apply
beta inverse to this. Okay. So what
we're going to get is v1 minus b1 times
the probability that beta inverse
of b1 is greater than.
So one way of thinking beta inverse is
saying okay let's suppose I bid B1 what
is the valuation
uh
that which
valuation using bidding function beta
would bid be one and we're saying that
valuation should be higher than everyone
else's valuations right uh but
mathematically we're just taking an
inverse uh okay so now we've simplified
things a bit I think one Key observation
to point out is, you know, the math has
gotten a little more complicated, but
the basic trade-off hasn't changed. When
I bid more, when I increase B1, the
first term gets smaller because when I
win, I win less because I have to pay
more.
What happens to the second term if beta
1 goes up?
It's actually easier to see maybe here.
If beta 1 goes up, this increases
because if I bid more, it's more likely
that I win. It's more likely that my bid
is higher than everyone else's. So
again, we face the basic trade-off. If I
bid more, I increase the chance that I
win, but I win less when I do win. And
we have to balance those two effects.
So we're almost there, but now we need
to analyze this expression. And what we
need to do is we need to understand the
distribution of the maximum of these
random variables. So this is where we're
going to use a little bit of math. We
basically need to compute what is the
distribution function of this maximum.
So we'll define let's say g of v
is equal to the probability that the
maximum
of v1 up to vn
is less than equal to v. Okay, this is a
definition and we want to try to
understand this function g, right? Well,
what does it mean for the maximum of
these random variables to be less than
or equal to v? Well, that's the same as
saying V1 is less than V. Ah, I
shouldn't have V1 here. This should be
V2. I apologize.
It's the same as saying V2 is less than
V. V3 is less than V all the way up to
VN is less than V, right? For the
maximum of things to be smaller than
something. That's going to be true
exactly if every single thing in the
maximum is smaller than that thing.
And the trick here is that we can use uh
independence.
So it turns out this is the equal to the
probability that V2 is less than equal
to V times all the way up to the
probability that VN
is less than equal to V because this is
the this occurs if and only if each of
these
events occurs. And because they're
independent the probability of the joint
occurrence of things is just the product
of the probabilities. This is like
saying the probability that I flip two
heads is just a half times a half. It's
one quarter. That's that's the fact that
we're using if they're independent. And
again, feel like whenever I go over
this, if you've seen this before, this
will be too slow. If you haven't seen
it, it'll be too fast. Um I think
there's not a good solution to that.
Do I have a can I simplify this
expression on the right side? Let's just
be clear of what my notation means.
Right? I have n minus one numbers here
and I'm taking the the product of them.
Right? This is one number. Then I have a
number for v3, a number for v4 all the
way up to vn. I have n minus one numbers
and I'm multiplying them together. Yes.
>> Isn't that just the CDF at V9?
>> Exactly. Right. Because what is the
probability that V2 is less than or
equal to V? Well, that's just F of V.
And the probability that V3 is less than
or equal to V, that's just F of V. So I
just get F of V multiplied by itself N
minus one times because I'm going from
two all the way up to N. So what I'm
going to get is f of v
to the n minus one.
Let's just make sure this makes sense.
Is g of v going to be bigger or smaller
than f of v? And let's see if this makes
sense.
So f of v is a number between 0 and one.
Right? So when we multiply a number
between when we raise a number between 0
and one to the power n minus one that
number is going to get smaller. And that
makes sense because the probability for
all of these things to be less than v is
certainly that's less likely than the
probability that a single one of them is
less than equal to v. And we can also
see another intuitive property of this.
What happens when n gets really really
big?
What happens to this right hand side?
Yeah.
>> Probability that you're
>> Yeah. So it gets really really small,
right? Um because the probability that
everyone else is less than V uh goes
goes down. So I just want to show this
kind of makes intuitive sense. Uh and
then one final piece of notation that'll
be helpful
is let me
maybe I'll out of space here. Let me go
to a new board.
Uh, actually realized it'll be good to
be close to this board. So, let's let's
go to this board instead.
Okay.
So I just wanted to define the density
the the cumul the probability density
function associated with G. So let's
define one other definition. little g
of v is equal to the derivative of big
g.
Well, if big g equals this, now I just
have to apply uh the chain rule and I'll
get n minus one
* f of v
to the n minus 2 * f of v. So I'm just
using the power rule to bring the n
minus one down and then the chain rule
to multiply by little f using the fact
that little f is the derivative of big
f.
If you're a little rusty on this, that's
not so important.
Okay, so with all these simplifications,
I think
we now have a pretty clean formula. We
have u1
of b1 given v1 beta is equal to v1 minus
b1 times
well we use our function g and we get g
of beta inverse
of b.
So all I've done is use our notation g
to apply to here. There's a little
wrinkle because this was a strict
inequality and big G is defined by a
weak inequality. But the probability
that the maximum takes a single value is
zero. So that doesn't make a difference.
So I can ignore that. Okay.
So now this is the expression we want to
maximize. Once again recognizing the
trade-off that as I increase B1, this
gets smaller and this gets bigger. So in
words, this is the probability that I
win.
The way we're expressing it is the
probability that I win is the
probability that everyone else's
valuation is below this magical
threshold. What's magical about this
threshold? This is the valuation that
they would have to have to bet to bid
exactly B1. So I'm going to win if every
single player's valuation is below the
valuation that they would need in order
to bid B1.
Okay. So now what I want to do is I want
to take the derivative of this
expression so that I can choose the B1
optimally. Right? I want to maximize
this function. This function is telling
me what my payoff is as a function of
how much I bid. So let me just take
derivatives and maximize this. So if I
take derivatives and evaluate the first
order condition, I'm going to get minus
Let's go through what I've done. I've
taken the derivative of the first term
is -1 and multiplied it by the second
term to get this. Then I've done the
first term times the derivative of the
second term. I've used the chain rule.
So when I take the derivative of this,
first I take the derivative of big g to
get little g and then I need to take the
derivative of beta inverse. But here I'm
using what's called the implicit
function theorem. The derivative of the
inverse is the inverse of the
derivative, right? It's the reciprocal
of the derivative. So this is just a
calculus fact. Um the slope of the
inverse is just one over the slope of
the original function. So I'm going to
get this here.
So now I have a formula for
what my optimal bid B1 should be. So my
optimal bid B1 has to satisfy this
formula. Okay, but I'm looking for an
equilibrium. So it must be the case that
this holds when B1
equals
beta of V1. Okay, this is kind of a
subtle point.
Let's understand what we're doing here.
This is a formula that's satisfied by my
optimal bid.
But in order for this to be an
equilibrium, my optimal bid must be beta
of V1.
because we want it to be the case that
if everyone else is using this bidding
function beta and my valuation is v1
then the optimal bid for me is exactly
uh beta of v1. So we know that this must
hold at beta of v1. So maybe a more
formal way of saying this. So why is
this true? Let me give kind of the
justification. It's because beta of v1
must be an element of the ar max
over b1 prime.
So of all the possible bids I could
choose as player one following my
equilibrium strategy must be the best
possible bid. So when I take derivatives
of this and set them to zero to find the
maximum that first order condition must
be satisfied by my maximizer beta of u1.
Uh I think this is maybe a little
subtle. This is kind of the key step. So
any questions here?
>> Yes.
>> So are you basically just saying that
this is only necessarily true if
>> exactly right. Yeah. So I'm I'm solving
for the optimal. This is a condition
that must be satisfied by my optimal
bid. But then I know that beta of v1
must be my optimal bid. So therefore
beta of of v1 must satisfy this
equation. And that's going to simplify
things a lot, right? So let me plug in
beta of v1 and see what I what I get
here.
And of course, the details of this are
all in the notes, but
I think if you don't see it kind of in
real time, it can get a little
overwhelming.
So, if we plug in beta of v1, we're
actually going to get things are
actually going to simplify a lot, right?
uh we're going to get
equals negative g of v1 right because
beta inverse of beta of v1 is just v1
and then we get plus v1 minus beta of v1
times g of v1
times
uh divided by
beta prime of v1.
So this is a much simpler formula and
we can actually simplify it a little
further.
We know we know we're allowed to divide
by this because beta prime is strictly
positive. Uh that's an assumption we
made over here. So let's multiply by
beta prime and move this to the other
side. And what we get is beta prime of
v1
g of v1
equals
and this is a necessary condition for
that our beta function must satisfy. in
order for us to have an equilibrium
where everyone uses the beta function.
Uh now I think we can actually intuit
this pretty nicely.
So here's some nice intuition for this.
Right? What I want to say is suppose my
value is v1
and I'm contemplating instead of bidding
beta of v1
I could bid beta of v1 plus epsilon.
Okay.
Well, let's think about epsilon being
very small, right? So, I'm supposed to
bid beta of v1. We want to see what
happens if I instead bid beta of v1 plus
epsilon. And this is approximately going
to be beta of v1
plus epsilon time b prime of v1.
This is just a tailor expansion.
So
if epsilon is really small
and positive,
what I claim is that
this is measuring the
gain.
I'm running more
And this is me measuring the additional
payment
to understand what's going on.
If I deviate from beta of v1 to beta of
v1 plus epsilon,
then
I'm going to win. How is that going to
change the probability that I win the
auction? Well,
it's only going to make a difference if
my opponent's if the maximum value of my
opponent is between V1 and V1 plus
epsilon.
If their valuation is between if the
maximum value of my opponents is between
V1 and V1 plus epsilon then when I bid
as if my valuation were V1 I lost. But
when I increase my bid to bidding beta
of V1 plus epsilon now I win.
Roughly the probability of that is
roughly
g of v1 * epsilon because it's the
density of my opponent's uh bid times
the width of this interval. So
what this right hand term is exactly
expressing is it's saying if I slightly
increase my bid I get my utility if I
win times a slightly higher probability
of winning which is exactly g of v1 *
epsilon. That's the amount by which my
winning probability goes up by bidding a
bit more. On the other hand, if I bid a
little bit more,
I have to bid I have to pay epsilon beta
prime of v1 a be whenever I win. So I
lose this much in additional payments
whenever I win. And what's the
probability that I win? Exactly G of V1.
So there's a very uh if you could really
had great intuition, you could maybe
jump right away to this formula by
thinking through this. But uh we derived
it with calculus, so uh it doesn't
matter. But I think um so to be very
precise what I'm saying is if instead of
bidding beta of v1 I bid beta of v1 plus
epsilon then my expected additional
payment would be approximately epsilon
times the left hand side and my expected
gain from winning more would be
approximately epsilon times the right
hand side and if I'm already an optimum
then the effect of this perturbation uh
must be zero. this is like a first order
condition and therefore I get this
equation but that may have been a little
a little subtle. So that's sort of how I
like to think about it but but if you
don't see that the first time I think
that's okay. Yeah. So the idea isn't
that in the formula you so you have to
like multiply the like both sides by
epsilon
>> right yeah
>> epilon is implicit
>> right so the argument is I get if I
multiply both sides by epsilon then you
know I guess 10 you know the more formal
argument would be I could actually
choose epsilon to be slightly you know a
small positive number or a small
negative number so because I can choose
it to be a small positive or negative
number the only way that I won't have a
profitable deviation is both sides of
this are equal.
>> CDF.
>> Yeah. So let's let's understand the role
of it, right? I'm saying what happens if
I bid slightly higher. Okay. Let's take
epsilon positive. Well, I the amount
more by which I bid is epsilon* beta
prime of v1. That's how much more I bid.
So you can think of that. Let's put the
limiting epsilon here. That's how much
more I'm bidding, right? But what's the
increase in how much I pay? Well, I
don't actually pay that extra amount
unless I win. What's the probability
that I win? It's the probability that
everyone else's value is below mine.
That's exactly G of V1. So, this is the
probability I win times the extra
payment I make if I do win. On the other
hand, I'm looking at the extra
probability that I win
is G * epsilon. That's what I get down
here. But then that marginal change in
how much I win is multiplied by the
utility I get when I do win. But I'll
admit this is a little if you you know
if you follow the math and you don't
fully see all this intuition, I think
that's that's okay the first time.
Okay. So now we want to solve this.
We're close. We uh we have this formula.
Let me erase the epsilons now.
Uh and now we have a differential
equation. And you know, this is not
really a course where we're trying to uh
test how well people can solve
differential equations, but this one
there's a pretty nice trick. So, let me
just um I want to get all the betas to
one side because we now have a
differential equation for beta. And now
we want to find the function beta that
satisfies this differential equation.
Okay, so if we move all the betas to one
side and let me also call my variable
now v instead of v1 just to make things
life a little easier. So then my
differential equation becomes beta prime
of v g of v plus beta of v g of v.
So this is my differential equation. So
formally what we've done is we've said
we've guessed that there exists an
equilibrium
in which everyone uses the bidding
function beta and then we've used the
properties of equilibrium to argue that
if that's the case then we know a lot
about what this beta function must be.
In fact it must satisfy this special
differential equation. And now we want
to solve for this differential equation.
Find the function that satisfies this. I
don't know if anyone's recently taken
differential equations, they may see um
there's kind of a something special
about this left hand side. Does anyone
anything pop out at you? I don't know if
you just took class on OD's.
>> Yeah,
>> looks like
>> exactly. So let's express the left hand
side as beta of V G of V.
Maybe I'll this is kind of sloppy
notation, but I mean the derivative of
this whole thing, right? Maybe I'll
write ddv. I don't know. Everyone has
different notation for derivatives.
Let's write that. Well, now I have the
derivative of something and I have
something else. So now I'm just going to
integrate this from V lower bar to V.
There's always an issue with um what
terms we use, but okay. So let's
integrate both sides from V lower bar to
well, we don't want to call it V because
we already have V here. So let's call it
Vhat. Okay. So on the left hand side we
get beta of v g of v
evaluated from v= v lower bar to let's
say v hat.
And on the right hand side we get the
integral from v lower bar to vhat of v
g of v dv.
So if these two sides are equal
certainly the integrals of the two sides
are equal. I've integrated the right
side from V lower bar to V upper bar and
I've also integrated the left side from
V lower bar to V upper bar. But this
just takes a really simple form because
I'm taking the integral of a derivative,
right? The integral of a derivative is
just the anti-derivative uh at the end
points, right? And this notation here
means I plug in V= V hat and then I
subtract the expression with V equals V
lower bar. I think this is pretty
standard notation. Um, okay. So maybe
I'll put in arrows and I'll write
integrate.
So now we're getting closer. But I'd
argue that this left hand side
simplifies even more. How can we
simplify this left hand side? What
happens at V lower bar?
>> Yeah.
>> G of V lower bar is
>> g of v lower bar is zero. So we can just
ignore that term that disappears, right?
Because we get zero times something. So
we only get the the top term. So we get
beta of vhat
time g of vhat on the left equals the
integral from v lower bar to v upper bar
of v g of v dv.
And now we've solved our differential
equation because we have beta by itself.
And now we can just divide by big g. So
let's divide
So we get our solution is beta. And this
big v is sort of annoying. So maybe I'll
change notation a little bit and write
beta of v. Let me just use v instead of
v hat and then maybe x instead of v. So
let me say this is the integral from v
lower bar to v of x g of x.
No.
So let me check. Wherever I had a v hat,
I want a v. And wherever I had a little
v, I want an x. Looks good.
So here's our
So what we've solved for is the bidding
function that every player is going to
use in this symmetric equilibrium. I
should warn that I should caution that
there's one kind of trick we've done.
Technically what we've shown is that if
there's an equilibrium of this form then
beta must look like this. But really we
have to check that if beta looks like
this it's actually an equilibrium. We've
sort of shown a necessary condition, not
a sufficient condition, but you can
check that this actually is an
equilibrium. So that's okay. It's sort
of like when you solve a maximization
problem and you set the derivative to
zero. Well, sometimes you don't have a
maximum, you have a minimum or something
that could be going on here, but we can
check that that's not what's going on.
So let's try to interpret this. Okay.
Well, we already have a formula for the
equilibrium in the special uniform case.
So let's see if this agrees with our
answer there. If it doesn't agree there,
then then we're kind of in trouble,
right? So in the uniform 01 case,
well what is G
of X and what is G of V?
Well, let's remember what G is. G is the
distribution
of
the maximum value of my opponents. But
if there's only two of us, then the
maximum value of my opponents is just
the value of my opponent. Right? So in
the uniform 01 with two bidters, what is
g of x going to be?
It's going to be the density of the
distribution of my opponent's value. And
what is that density in the uniform
case? Just one, right?
Okay. And what is g of v going to be?
Well, it's the CDF of the uniform
distribution. So that's just V, right?
The probability that a uniform
distribution is below V is just V
assuming V is between 0 and one, right?
So let's plug this in. And I guess the
final step is V lower is equal to zero.
Right? So these are all the, you know,
the special restrictions we get in this
uniform example with two players. I
should say two bidters.
Let's see. Guess we'll see in real time
if we've made a mistake. I don't think
we have, but we'll see. So, we get the
integral from 0 to v
of
x
over v
dx.
x * 1 / v dx.
Well, that's just 1 / v is a constant.
We can take that out of the integral
from 0 to v of x dx.
What is the anti- derivative of x? It's
just x^2 over 2. So, we get v ^2 over 2
* 1 over v.
And fuel, we didn't get it wrong. We got
v over two. So that's good. So this
formula is consistent with our guess in
the very special case. But this is a
much more general formula.
Now how can we interpret this formula?
Um is actually quite a nice way of
looking at this. Does this fraction
remind you of anything? I don't know.
Does anyone see a way of interpreting
this this integral
in terms of conditional expectations? So
g of v is the probability that all my
opponent's valuations are below v and g
of x is the density of the distribution
of the maximum of my opponent's
valuations. So it turns out that this is
actually a conditional expectation.
Again, this is sort of a probability
fact. So it turns out what is this?
It's actually the
expectation
of the max
of V2 through VN conditional on the
event that this maximum is less than or
equal to V.
So this gives us uh a nicely
interpretable formula. What does this
say? How much do I bid in the
equilibrium of the first price auction
when my value is v? What I'm actually
bidding is
the expectation
of the highest value of my opponents
condition on the event that the highest
value of my opponents is less than or
equal to V, less than or equal to my
true valuation.
Um,
and sort of a a nice connection here.
Maybe I'll try to do it. Uh, but let me
pause. See, I feel like I've lost people
a little bit. So, any any question? I
know it's been a little mathier than
we've normally done. So, any any
questions here? Yeah, let's let's pause.
Yeah.
>> So, that the condition is that like your
valuation is higher than the valuation
is higher than the valuation of the
maximum components, right?
>> Like what if that's not true?
>> Uh, so you ask about this final step.
Okay. So, let's understand right here. V
is just a number, right? So what I'm
writing here is just a formula for just
something that's defined as a function
of this number V. So mathematically all
this is is a very special conditional
expectation where this is a random
variable. This is a random variable and
I'm just looking at a very special
conditional expectation of a random
variable. So uh it may be that their
valuations are lower than mine. What
we're just saying is it's kind of a
thought experiment. It's saying how much
am I going to bid? Well, one way I can
compute my equilibrium bid is by
computing this very special uh
conditional expectation.
Uh but you're right that the true value
of my opponents may be lower than V.
This is just kind of a formula for what
my bid uh will be. Yeah.
>> But it could also be that the true value
is higher than right.
>> It could be. Yeah.
>> But you're just saying like you're
basing it off of the idea that if
everything were less than or equal to
>> I can just define this conditional
expectation. So for now it's I mean it's
just a definition. It's not like um you
know it's just a function of v and it's
a number we can compute. Uh but it gives
us kind of a nice interpretation that
I'll go through in a second. Yeah.
>> Uh yes in the back.
>> Can you explain one more time why g of x
over g of b is that?
>> Yeah. Okay. Um and this is something.
Yeah. If you haven't seen me. So this is
um
>> say it again. put it because like xg of
x is an expectation.
>> So this is an unconditional expectation.
When I put the g over v here, it becomes
a conditional expectation.
>> I wonder why the x is in the circle.
>> Uh oh, I guess. So it's a question of
what we circle. So I'm saying the
conditional expectation can be expressed
as x times the conditional density. So
what I've circled here is the
conditional density. So this is the
conditional density given the event that
everyone else's value is below a certain
thing. So maybe I'll just say what's the
general property I'm using here. Um
go go go down here and kind of write
this kind of math fact.
Um
so
if you have a random variable X
distributed with a density G
then we can also compute the conditional
density. So we can say what is the
conditional density g of x given
that x is less than or equal to v
and that's defined to be g of x divided
by the probability that x is less than
or equal to v which is exactly g of x
times big g of v.
One way to think about this is
if I want to understand the conditional
probability or the conditional
distribution of X given that X is below
V, well, it's still proportional to the
density, but now it has to integrate to
one over this condition of N. So
conditional on my opponent's value being
below V, the conditional density, if I
integrate it from V lower bar to V,
better give me one because that's how
conditional distributions work. And if
we do this integral from v lower bar to
v of g of x, we exactly get big g of v.
And then if we divide it by big g of v,
we get one. So this is just kind of a
it's a normalization to ensure that the
uh distribution the conditional
distribution integrates to to one. Uh
but again, as I said, we're using a
little more probability. This is maybe
the one lecture where we're kind of
leaning on some of these official
prerects that we haven't really
enforced. And um yeah, some of these
things may take a little a little
refresher, but uh this is the general
fact that I'm using.
Any other any other questions? Um okay,
so one kind of final observation if we
try to look at this equation star,
let's uh go over here.
So we said that if my valuation is V,
this is how much I bid. So if I win the
good, the amount that I'm going to pay
is exactly beta of V, which is exactly
this formula over here. But let's just
go through a little thought experiment.
Okay, let's suppose that we instead
we did a second price auction instead of
a first price auction.
Well, now
Everyone's going to bid truthfully.
Okay.
So,
let's say
the profile of valuations is V1 through
VN.
If we're all bidding truthfully and
we're now in a second price auction,
when is bidder one going to win? What
must be true about V1 through VN for
bidder one to to win the item? Yeah.
>> Yeah. So maybe another way I'll say it
is so bidder one wins
if V1
is greater than or equal to maybe I'll
say greater than I'll say greater than
equal to the max of V2
up to VN.
And if they win, what do they pay?
How much does bidder one pay if they win
the auction?
Well, bidder one pays the second highest
bid, right? The second highest bid is
going to be the highest bid of his
opponents, but his opponents are bidding
truthfully. So the second highest bit is
exactly going to be the maximum
of V2 up to VN.
So
in a second price auction as opposed to
a first price auction, the amount that I
pay is random. I don't know how much I'm
going to pay because it's going to
depend on the valuations of my
opponents. But the amount that I'm going
to pay is exactly this. And I'm going to
pay that exactly if I win. Right? So
what is the expected amount that I'm
going to pay given that I win?
It's exactly going to be. So suppose I
win.
What is my conditional expected payment?
It's exactly the expectation of this
condition on the event that this is less
than equal to V1. Wait a second.
That's exactly the formula we got over
here. So this is an expression of
revenue equivalence. It says that in a
first price auction and a second price
auction, the expected amount that each
type of bidder pays is actually going to
be the same. Here I bid B of V. It's
just it's one number and I always pay
that if I win. Here, how much I pay
depends on what other people bid. I
don't know what I'm going to pay. If
other people have valuations really
close to mine, I'm going to pay a lot.
If they all have valuations really low,
I'm going to pay a little. But the
expected amount that I'm going to pay is
actually going to be exactly the same as
the amount that I pay in the first price
auction. And this is the first
indication of this revenue equivalence
fact that uh while the way that we bid
is going to be different, the expected
amount that we each bidder pays is going
to be the same. And for that reason, the
auctioneers's revenue expected revenue
is also going to be the same. So this is
sort of the first hint at something
called revenue equivalence, which we saw
in a special example before. And now we
see is a much more general phenomena.
But we'll talk about that a bit more uh
next class. I guess it's a holiday on
Tuesday. So I guess I'll see everyone uh
next Thursday. And I'm happy to stick
around uh with any questions. Thanks.